toutes les informations 100% des
informations de gym c'est sûr c'est sur
internet alors je me permets
d'intervenir
oui parce que monsieur dit dans sa vidéo
présente moi j'ai regardé j'étais très
curieux de savoir quelles étaient les
faits nouveaux que je pouvais dont je
pouvais prendre connaissance d'excel
quelque chose d'une affluence aux
nouvelles qui est qui qui n'avait pas
été mise à disposition du public
auparavant j'ai pas trouvé
moi ce que monsieur affirme que les
policiers ont pas eu effectivement dans
la presse la possibilté s'exprimer c'est
normal parce qu'ils ont été incarcérés
mais je pense qu'en france aujourd'hui
on incarcère pas les gens comme ça dans
toutes les affaires qui sont peints qui
sont pas à décider de les mettre en
prison est aujourd'hui sont sous
contrôle judiciaire donc on n'est pas
dans une posture qui est neutre
alors vous êtes ancien fonctionnaire
moyen aura des comme vous une hausse
portera vouliez dessus ouais c'est bien
l'info vous faut devenir ministre de
l'intérieur à las vegas et les basques
sont les patients juste bruno pas
patience ils pensent que donc voilà je
suis policier ma carte est ici pour
suspendu six mois pour information oui
oui vous vous êtes d'extrême droite donc
voilà donc si vous voulez on colle des
étiquettes seafrance police un syndicat
d'extrême radio comme ça on s'est loupé
c'est incroyable non mais voilà pourquoi
j'ai demandé mon détachement ses encours
bon bref c'est pas le voile attendait
pourtant les prix ont compris que vous
alliez l'extrême droite c'est le sujet
qui vous plaît sinon le reste on va
rester sur michelle a atterri sur wii
dont on aimerait entendre votre version
allégée mais la version à l'éclair j'ai
trois policiers qui sont dans une nasse
sur la vidéo regardez bien je demande à
tout le monde d'aller regarder sur
touche pas à mon flic on voit éclair qui
bloque la porte on voit éclair qui
essaye de piquer la balle à la matraque
de mes collègues on voit est clair
qu'ils ont comme en mai qui bloque tout
il aurait fait ça ne sais quoi tu
c'était quoi son but il a hélas il a
fait un guet-apens pour vous non non
c'est pas un guet-apens alors c'est quoi
écouter ils se retrouvent là pour moi il
veut pas être interpellé c'est une
évidence
après moi je j'essaie de comprendre
pourquoi et je lui dis dans ma vidéo je
dis quoi
pourquoi il fait ça et donc j'ai cherché
je me suis dit et donc on a cherché
ensuite on a regardé qui a des trucs un
peu bizarres
un mec qui met la main comme ça c'est
clair qu'ils regardaient dans sa
chaussette
l'image est bizarre on peut finir avez
vous alors non mais maintenant le temps
est très court est ce que je peux à
nouveau avec temps la louisiane en fait
ce dont sont accusées ces policiers
c'est effectivement les violences on va
pas revenir dessus à 180 jours d'itt et
et je suis pas juge effectivement je
connais pas c'est pas le nom de bob att
qui compte c est légitime à faux en
écriture c'est à dire qu'ils ont eu la
parole puisque les policiers ont la
possibilité de s'exprimer à travers des
procès verbaux ils sont assermentés nous
c'est à dire que leurs paroles ne peut
pas en théorie est remise en question
ils sont poursuivis sans maxime pour un
crime parce qu'il faut savoir que le
faux en écriture est poursuivi par le
code de procédure pénale comme un qu'ils
sont innocents au même niveau que le
meurtre ou le viol donc on n'est pas sur
une procédure
c'est un crime cerci jugés en cour
d'assises juste